so this is Taylor Kitsch is second film
with Peter Berg
let's hope it's better than battleship
[Music]
lone survivor is directed by Peter Berg
and stars Mark Wahlberg Taylor Kitsch
Ben Foster Emile Hirsch
and Eric Bana this is based on the true
story of four Navy SEALs that are sent
after this al-qaeda terrorist to take
him out they get pinned down by fire and
this is the story of how they work as
hard as they possibly can to survive
lone survivor actually opened last year
very late in 2013 and an extremely
limited release very few people were
able to see this movie and now I'm
finally able to see it and tell you guys
this is a very intense movie and a very
well made movie I can honestly say this
is one of the fastest pace films I have
ever seen the two-hour run time went by
like that in fact when it ended I was
like oh really that was two hours
because essentially the second and third
act of this movie is really just a
humongous action scene and to say action
scene is kind of a menial way to
describe what has really taken place in
this movie because you watch these four
guys go through hell and back and you're
thinking to yourself this actually
happened some of these men were shot
multiple times to an absurd degree and
they're still crawling around trying to
survive and trying to fight for their
country and it really gets your
adrenaline pumping because these action
scenes are filmed with brutal intensity
this is a very violent movie but it's
not gratuitously violent just to be
violent it is an extremely accurate
depiction of the things that took place
in the guys book who actually wrote this
now Mark Wahlberg plays the main
character in this movie and his
character is placed with an extremely
difficult decision in fact all the men
are basically the rest of the movie
hinges on if they had made a certain
decision or not and so the movie does
have a bit of a moral dilemma in it as
well it's not just a straight-up action
film now my main issue with the movie
that makes it not like this mind blowing
experience for me but instead a very
good film is the fact that I didn't
really care so much for the characters
now I'm not demeaning the actual men the
men who really went through these things
those guys are just that's incredible
that that took place what I'm talking
about is really the filmmaking I didn't
really care so much for the characters
because the movie starts out and it has
you know their typical scenes where the
characters are running around they're
training they're talking they're joking
they're poking fun at each other and a
lot of the humor felt kind of forced and
you just didn't really care so much for
the characters once the actions
it's it was a very exciting and well
done movie with incredible stunt work
and Peter Berg definitely liked scenes
where actors fall down hills for a very
long time if you saw the run down you
know exactly what I'm talking about that
scene was played for comedy in here it's
absolutely bone crushing and you're
wincing the entire time the action is
done extremely well the last two thirds
of this movie feel like a nonstop ride
that never ends I just wish I cared a
little bit more about the characters
nevertheless though this is an extremely
well-done film in regards to what it
tries to accomplish and what it's trying
to accomplish is detail the horrific
things these guys had to go through for
this very brief period of time and you
are with them every step of the way and
it's riveting Mark Wahlberg was very
good in this movie this is one of the
best performances I think he's ever
given and Taylor Kitsch also did a
really good job I think he's pretty good
as a supporting role he lends a lot as a
supporting character Emile Hirsch and
Ben Foster were all so fantastic all the
actors really had a good sense of
brotherhood and you could really tell
they were trying to honor the events
that took place also major props to
whoever did the makeup the makeup in
this movie turned my stomach all I know
I think this is a very exciting and
well-made movie I didn't care about the
characters as much as I wanted to but
the actors performances Peter Berg's
very good direction and the mind-blowing
action sequences definitely make this a
film you should check out at some point
it is very gruesome though I will warn
you ahead of time I'm gonna give lone
survivor a B+ so guys if you have seen
the movie what do you think of it what
do you think of the characters decisions
they make throughout the film what do
you think of Peter Berg's direction did
he redeem himself since battleship
did you like battleship because though I
don't hate battleship it just it just
wasn't really all that great guys thanks
as always for watching and if you like
this you can click right here and get
stuck mine eyes
[Music]